like I was a very happy kid but I hated  school like on a different planet was  getting these nets and the world was  telling me I was a loser my my teachers  were telling me a loser my friend's  parents weren't saying to my face that I  was a loser but I could see in their eye  that I didn't think I'd be successful  because the game I played on like  today's game in the 80s early 90s was  school was the way out going to Harvard  was the great accomplishment not  building Facebook or Instagram or being  a successful entrepreneur was a  different landscape and so you know the  Y was to [ __ ] stick to everybody like  I used to sit there as a 13 14 15 16  year old and look at my class my  teachers are like I'm gonna show you I'm  gonna show all of you  you think I suck I'm gonna be the  biggest best person on earth  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]